hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to oxygen not included
everything is going swimmingly
beautifully delightfully there's not a
thing wrong going on in this Pigpen of
ours so we just need to be very happy
that everything is wonderful beautiful
awesome and incredible we are making
some improvements we're going to extend
the poop container and with the poop
container extended we can definitely
rest assured that we are not going to be
absolutely dying from the lack of oxygen
and temperature look at that we've got
our poop container at maximum i okay
everything's fine and we've got one open
bed which means that it's time to
welcome someone new to our home this is
great I like to both you but we already
got someone like you so we we need a
gozman or as I like to call them a slump
Oh literally I I'm like
Michael Myers I'm like Steve Buscemi I'm
like from the office the the manager I'm
like like Michael Myers Mike Wazowski
Mike Michael Scott no I'm like Michael
Scott I identify the first physical
characteristic that I see and I apply
that to your name so you were slumped
over so your slump off so everybody say
hi to slump oh here hi swamp oh how you
doing that's tinkle hey how you doing
yeah you just came out of the ether yeah
you did it absolutely nothing oh that's
a problem oh that's right it's not a
problem because I'm about to make it not
be a problem because this is how smart I
am
guys watch guys watch this is such a
genius idea
never mind they're gonna do that
tomorrow I mean apparently they can
still pump it which is kind of amazing
but whatever I guess that still
physically works oh we don't have a pump
and they're not gonna have any water for
their showers oh I guess it's still
there's still some in the pipes so I
guess it sucks it out for some reason
and this is your bed where you slump oh
slum ball Oh lump has already got it no
slump oh no that's not your bed you
haven't done much nicer bed now just try
it now Zombo destroy destroy destroy oh
you don't need to be there Lobo fine
slump oh he's not gonna destroy because
slump pose a jerkwad we're out of power
who'd have thought unrefrigerated food
yeah I know
we've got sixty nine thousand four
hundred and twenty calories and I just
don't have anything to do about that I
think if we waste a little food it's
gonna be fine bros got their bath time
whoo-hoo
what about slump slump Oh needs we could
have another researcher you want to be a
researcher right so why not give
research just because if they have
research then they can help out instead
of he who being the only one but you
also want a critter wrangling we could
do both we can have you do both there's
no reason why you would only need to do
one let's get you some advanced
researching because that helps you learn
other skills too unless that's changed
I'm thinking about old miss all right
hey slump aw you get that one that's you
slump oh that's you have they cracked
open the egg yet no they're about to
though hey can you crack this open I
want to see this horrible ID there we go
that didn't do as much it was oh there
it is the waves are propagating that's
night that didn't all right I know fluid
dynamics and I'm 100% sure that this is
not the way the fluid dynamics is
supposed to work so just saying there
probably needs to be a little better
fluid dynamic if I were to be perfectly
hey wow this this broke open
oh god no does that mean oh no that's
leaking we need to close that off but
it's really hot down there so uh we're
urging sea closed-off that's probably
good they'll fix it fixed forever
I say fixed forever I say never have to
worry about it again I say I say it all
better
forever and ever and no one will ever
question how good I am at managing
everything also where's my uh where's my
hatch we're at the hatch go hope -
didn't leave that's that's no good
attribute increase who introduced who
athletics food wonder if athletics
actually helps with that I've never
known if the manual generator is
actually helped by athletics generation
but maybe hey yeah yeah make it nice and
cool in here make it nice and cool yeah
yeah that's what's doing it
yes goods goods goods good stuff it's
pretty good yeah pump it Pump that cold
I need a better system for keeping
things relatively insulated through it
door I don't think this is doing it good
enough but hey it's the best that we can
do at the moment I don't know why that
coal generators aren't being done
anymore they still hooked up why is no
one doing the coal generators like
that's supposed to be helping us and yet
we're not doing anything about it also
it's heating up our water supply which
is again not a very smart thing that I'm
doing but I'm not a very smart person so
I guess I can't really say anything
about it but whatever it's it's still
not very smart of me to do something
like that
oh whoops wise way that doesn't work
anymore
why is that there I really shouldn't
have made the the ranching pit right
above the water supply should I have
that seems like an erroneous thing for
me to do at this juncture now I'm
starting to realize that maybe there was
a bit of a problem with me doing that
thing thus that thing that it is doing
so perhaps mayhaps it's not the greatest
of ideas even though I think that it
might be it actually is not the ideas
that I have in my brain are sometimes
not the greatest that ever existed and
in fact are occasionally those that
which are full of nightmares anyway
anyway are we doing okay on what no the
answer's no ooh
we've reached we've breached we breached
we breached the ocean ah the sweet salty
brine I don't know how far that goes but
that's a lot of oh you're steaming
you're steaming it uh-oh
all right cool yeah you keep blasting it
until you eventually the pressure gets
too big and then it explodes that'll be
a problem but until that happens I'm not
gonna worry about it because I'm not a
worrying kind of person what I need to
do here is I need to make a pump I know
I'm not gonna be able to power it just
yet but I'm gonna need to make a pump it
could probably be here for now and then
I'll move it later but I'm gonna need a
pump and then I'm gonna need to
eventually power it now I'm gonna worry
about a separate power supplied
specifically just for this one it's it's
gonna be part of the same circuit if I
can put a coal one up here say right
here the coal carbon dioxide would spill
downward and then you know it wouldn't
necessarily be that so if I have this
connected up through here yeah and then
that would generally be able to power
all that and we would get some kind of a
liquid delivery no no wait wait wait no
no no and then this would go into a
separate dump because I don't want to
necessarily have this being the same
dump it's fine if they're on top of each
other I think there's no problem with
that
right it's all clean water all right
good good good how we doing on germs
better or were more contained
that's a longer
so they're gonna work on that and then
that's gonna be all good and then we're
gonna have a way to get more water big
water not just like little bits of water
but I'm talking like big honking water
everybody loves big honking water I love
big honking water you love big honking
water
everyone loves big honking water who
doesn't
crazy people freaks even not me I'm not
a freak and let me research something
Madison sounds good let's go let's go
Madison full on medicine medicinally
we're gonna get some medicine izing
there's a lot of carbon dioxide
happening in here I'm not a harbor sense
sure if there's something I should do
about that or if it's actually gonna be
okay so long as it's contained to there
I mean it's it's relatively fine I could
put some airflow tiles through here so
eventually it would leak out I mean
technically speaking if I airflow these
the water wouldn't leak out but the air
would which is all I really need is it
that simple I think it might be that
simple huh oh I'm waiting for the oxygen
just to die out everywhere because we're
so packed full of oxygen everywhere I
really didn't need as much as I had I'm
gonna get it to a point where I can be
self-sustaining what are you looking
here who cares go away
[Music]
oh kia now that the airflow tile would
come out then there'd be enough right
thankfully it seems the stress has gone
down and i think that's largely in part
with the oxygen not being so absurdly
incredibly girthy that everyone's ears
explode anything that's a big help
still got a long way to go on this
project here but it should be done
relatively quickly and hey you know that
whole like long commute thing but kind
has gone away well they're sleeping when
we look at the colony summary just to
see like the travel time if that's gone
down okay calorie oxygen consumed it's
spiked up with the new member 84 to 85
you know surprisingly glows like it's
it's really not that bad
total work time efficiency is up total
travel time it's still high but and it's
trending down I guess I don't know
average work time oh no that's gone down
average stress created domesticated
critters one no it's funny we had one
and then one was gone my next goal I
think is you know they eat such garbage
meals that I think we're gonna have to
set up a system where they start to eat
a little better but in order to do that
the very minimum that I need is bristle
berries and I've got nothing wrong with
getting bristle berries in the host it's
getting really thirsty in here there's
nothing wrong with having bristle
berries except that they take water
waters the big thing and until I can
start draining the ocean I can't really
afford to make bristle berries because
that's water that's just gone that water
goes away and yeah we have a steam vent
which is very good it's good to have a
steam vent right here because that is
quite literally an unlimited source of
water well we don't know is just if it's
actually going to be useful to me or not
I'm not sure how steam then changed
remember back way back when if you've
been watching this for a while remember
when steam vents would just produce an
unlimited amount of water all the time
and he was way too much water and they
erupted way too often which just meant
that eventually over time if you got let
to like cycle a thousand your entire
place was just water and that was it
nothing else besides there's water
there's
or as the eye can see so yeah we're
gonna try to avoid that what happens if
you get to the bottom cuz all this is
just like a sphere right it's just a big
sphere asteroid what happens if you get
to the bottom no you can't get to the
bottom because the bottom actually has a
limit the up is the thing that has the
space so I don't need to worry about
that that's fine that's all good
I'm not worried about that priorities I
need to put you researching and ranching
which is a weird combination but
whatever and this is kind of working the
carbon dioxide is starting to flood and
then these things are starting to take
care of it so that's good Oh looks like
we're almost ready to go for the
desalinization as soon as we get our
power up oh they can't reach that oh I'm
an idiot I'm dumb okay you and I think
my favorite thing about this game is and
what's drawn me to it
since the very beginning it's literally
just the name it's part I mean it's it's
part of the name it's in the name the
oxygen there is something so viscerally
pleasant about this floating fluid blue
sparkly oxygen there's something so nice
about the idea of filling up a space
with oxygen to make sure that these
things can just breathe I think there's
something like deeply connected to human
nature is like oh yeah I don't want to
not breathe not breathing is like the
worst thing so I gotta make sure these
guys have oxygen and it's such a
pleasant blue I don't think this game
would be merely as cool without that
kind of fluid dynamics enabled oxygen in
here and it's it's so it's so perfect -
because polluted oxygen like good it's
dirty I don't like that get it out of
here like there's something there just
is something so viscerally nice about
this idea with the polluted oxygen and
like just all of it in general and
actually what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
put a deodorizer down here so that we
can have that are we done here yet oh
there we go
now we're getting it MIMO is just the
best by the way can I say that MIMO is
just phenomenal like the only person
that's really building here and yeah
building does take a little bit of time
but at the same time Nima is just super
the best like the best like the best
we must kill it it every day memo's
killing it any
I just wanted to say that Mimas really
doing good I don't think I have the
morale to get everybody doing things I
could give people some tinkering cuz
there's not enough people that are able
to operate stuff maybe some tinkering
yeah but just give everyone baseline
tinkering because I feel like that's
important oh you're already up there
I'll worry about you later carrying
strength I guess strength to be good for
you tinkle - ish tidying yeah oh why
does tinkle to have so much morale
tickles dishes so Marilyn iced holy crap
okay Turner just a little bit tinkering
uh static design evil babyface a cropped
ending good old dumpling Oh Oh too much
not enough morale why does someone has
so much morale and someone does not
probably cuz they spend so much time in
this nice aesthetically that's probably
what is they spend so much time in this
lovely place of decor that they end up
never needing to worry about stress
because their morale is just so ungodly
high very interesting something to
consider maybe I need to improve the
decorum of this entire area I don't have
anyone as a dedicated tidier maybe I
should have someone has a dedicated tidy
or Turner right now is like the supplier
but frankly I don't even know if we need
that what if we have you be the plumber
I don't know if that plumbing you're our
plumber that's good it's just as good as
your plumber look at you you're here to
tidy up I guess that's good yeah
you're still doing the same basic thing
but you've been promoted you're no
longer just an errand boy you're a pure
mole we done here my mom bang mommy ma
go go go hurry hurry hurry man me my
you're good at building but this still
takes a long time Wow that's three
hundred and twenty five percent
construction bead right there now that's
in there
let's get Cole and bought a bingo bought
a boom that will be just the cool
generator for this and then suddenly
will have desalinization going on and I
don't know how much desalinization we're
gonna get but I'm expecting a deluge a
flood of water I'm expecting so much
water that we won't even be able to
tolerate how much water we have here
that's how much water I mean
why is there so much poopy water why is
there poopy water here why is there a
thin line of poopy water is it because I
drained it from here it's because I
drained it from here I drained it from
the slime poopy area hey look we've got
a nice natural thing of reed fiber here
that's good all right can we get this to
have some coal please I wish there was a
button that was like the goal in here
hey we need some coal evil baby face
you're not doing anything you're not
doing nothing what are you doing you're
doing nothing I don't even know what
does the Hat do it's not like it limits
them to the job what does the Hat do I
don't think the Hat does nothing I think
the Hat is just an aesthetic thing I
think that has to synthetic eggshells
are the edge tools here lik see and I'm
turning up the game volume cuz I think
it was a bit quiet he's a little late to
be saying in the episode 8 but you know
I kind of want the volume generally be
nice and audible I don't want it too
quiet too quiet too bad it's very fine
line don't mess it up you mess it up
everyone's gonna be mad I'm gonna be mad
everyone's gonna be up don't mess it up
you can't mess it up don't stop oh are
you sure oh is that too quiet
Oh too loud wait no hang on it might be
too quiet do loud
wait no is that too loud I think I can
hear it too much oh no now I can't hear
it at all okay that's pretty good yeah I
think you're fine maybe you sure didn't
think so I'm just messing with you am i
maybe not maybe maybe not probably not
maybe so
make sure you get it right hey is this
working now can I get some goddamn coal
in here yellow alert coal cool all right
here we go here we go here we go it's
happening Oh baby
Oh baby look at that look at that oh
that's a lot of salt water that we're
gonna be bumping up
oh yeah pump it baby pump it you're not
gonna have a home anymore pump it yeah
yeah plump baby pump all right here we
go here we go here we go here we go it's
about to happen oh yes okay go oh yeah
that's not as desalinization as I was
hoping it's about half a kilogram so it
does about as much as those so
technically speaking you would need two
of them to really get it going but hey
as an additional source of water that's
pretty good now we've got water being
created and we have salt which I think
if I'm not mistaken it said that salt
improves the quality of meals right so
people can stop complaining about the
stupid meals it will be at least 40
degrees Celsius or hotter if the input
materials are hot okay whatever I guess
that's fine whatever who cares what's
the temperature at foot fine that's a
lot of heat quite a cooler 1/4 the
cooling quaffed
there oh that's not good oh that's not
good wait no hang on that's actually bad
that is borderline bad we don't need
these lights these lighters generating
Heat what are we doing we're crazy why
do I have lights in here they're
practically roasting it alive oh why
didn't I just realize that how many
times if people told me that I don't
care no backseat gaming let me die let
me die get rid of them get rid of them
come on let's get rid of their producing
heat oh I'm so stupid of course they're
producing heat their lights what am i
insane oh god what have I been doing
they produce heat Oh fool maybe it'd be
better I need to have like the cooling
in the central location like right here
I get the idea between pumping cold air
around but it also might just be better
if I actually have
the cold air right where I needed to be
you know what I mean you know what I
mean hello
salt water not what I care about algae
that's better
we're doing pretty good on algae by the
way he why is there so much poopy air
where's don't take your O's is full the
beds full I probably need another one of
those yeah I'm gonna make another one of
those cuz I don't think I need two of
these yeah I don't think I need two of
those okay desalinization
going good we'll get a nice salt where's
our salt salt water where's salt give me
salt I want to see the salt you won't
see the salt
where's rahmanir old no where's her
story of salt in you salt can be refined
into table salt what's stupid well
that's dumb let's just dumb you're dumb
that's just stupid
Oh God I did yeah they're they're really
warm bye where the lights works 29.9
that's what it was doing that was
killing me just having those there at
least those are going that's nice I
guess
really cold stuff nice chili good it is
good stuff what am I gonna get the air
conditioner I don't know when's the air
conditioner I don't have research going
because avid idiot is so I obviously
don't have any research HVAC there we go
that's what I needed even though I'm not
gonna be able to do anything about that
ooh espresso machine that would be a
waste because I know the espresso
machine would require us to have hot
water but I kind of like it but I don't
like it that much we need to worry about
temperature first and foremost cuz this
is not an equivalent exchange I know
that for a fact but this is generally
the idea behind these air conditioning
now if I could find an ice biome which
maybe there is one maybe there's not I
have no idea I don't see one in the
immediate vicinity so I think I'm
generally just like boner owned it's
getting colder over there
there might be something up there there
might be something up that way no just
warm just very warm oh that's all very
warm very warm that's so warm it's it's
so warm down there why why is it so warm
that's what you would call not good I
don't know why that's cold like that
okay so best bet seems to be up over
here but then there's an other guys are
here from that neutronium
that I can see so yeah hot on that
somewhat of a standstill because even if
I've got the desalinization happening
I'm still running into the problem of
not enough water I need water that's
first and foremost maybe I should but
then they'd be hot water and then I
would know and then I wouldn't have that
it's getting better it's going down it's
going down it was twenty nine point
seven now it's going down because those
lights aren't there anymore
I was beaming lights onto them for no
other reason than I'm an idiot is gonna
be insulated just because I see some
heat leaking through here and I don't
like it
just around this area here zero stress
though in zero sick that's one evil baby
stays got stressed probably cuz as evil
plans aren't working how we doing on
oxygen okay we're getting back down to a
more reasonable level but we're still
doing pretty okay so I don't need to
turn any more on just yet let me go
ahead and destroy these these don't make
any sense down here because this is just
it's just a terrible terrible terrible
stupid place to have a ranch why would I
have that there doesn't make any sense
at all
oh yeah twenty nine point one oh nine
point nine point four twenty nine point
two okay temperature is going down god I
was dumb why was I so stupid alright so
what I what I could do now okay maybe I
should take advantage no then it just
make hot water okay temperature I can't
utilize anything with heat because it's
just gonna ruin the entire environment
that I have if I use things to filter
water with heat I'm gonna die so I just
cannot do that so I have to find other
means there's an ocean over here it's
relatively cool I mean the cold vacuum
of space would be a good place to get my
heat down but you know frankly I don't
think I want to do that just yet I think
of what I need to do is I need to I need
to figure out a way to start getting
refined materials but it's so much power
that's needed got it so much power maybe
I just need more battery maybe I need
like way bigger battery banks but then I
just those generate heat that's problem
I don't know is there a way to win I
don't know it's not a problem a battery
storage is a problem just generating the
power and the
first place like that's the issue I just
don't have enough power cuz my problem
right now is these guys are always on
those they they know no other life but
being on those generators just because
they can never fill it up even though
I've got say coal generator no not right
now anyway even though I've got say a
coal generator that's helping them out
it's never gonna be enough see even if
they're running Mac's flat out they
still aren't making enough power to
offset the consumption so the problem
isn't necessarily storage its generation
so I need to get a better way to get
power wood burner I don't have any wood
hydrogen I don't have any hydrogen coal
I've got coal but coals not unlimited
yeah I can't have them just live their
entire life here even though it's a good
life with all the decor that they have
and the lovely shine bugs and the lovely
little animals that are gonna die soon I
can't have them just have that because
that's no way to live it's just no way
to live I gotta do something better for
that which means I gotta figure out a
way to get power so the only other power
thing I have is hydrogen and just
because I don't have hydrogen doesn't
mean that I can't get hydrogen what I
kind of do is I kind of find it like a
hydrogen ven cuz this isn't gonna be
enough hydrogen to do anything with I
mean hydrogen is a good source but it's
not the best source because it's just
very difficult to it's very difficult to
get hydrogen bleach stone there's price
of new materials in here that I don't
fully understand okay let me just put
I'm gonna put the coal generators at a
level six priority just because I want
to try to get it so that these guys
don't have to work all the time every
time and I want the coal to be right
next to them coal star is gonna be right
here and it's gonna be a higher priority
than the other goal so that should be
helping them now it's going up good now
it's going up even though they're doing
it it is going up and hopefully
overnight it won't be going down so I
think I think just like for now the only
thing that I can do is I got to
continually just feed coal into it
because coal is a much easier material
to feed into it than hydrogen right now
I just I have to rely on coal power for
now because like the other option is
just like how how else am I gonna do
this there's no other way to do this
besides getting these coal generators
going as fast as they can because I need
these to boot duplicants I need these
three
kids I need them on my side you should
not be on that the batteries that you're
powering are fine
yeah the batteries that you're powering
are more than enough you just got
nothing else to do in your bored
I guess not you don't have any research
to do ah so we got HVAC so that's good
uh maybe some more automation hazard
protection transit tubes it'd be pretty
good but what we well I think we need is
eventually we need this kind of stuff
yeah this advanced stuff cuz I want to
get plastic manufacturing going because
I know a lot of materials require
plastic in the in the in the endgame of
this one there's a lot of things that
need plastic you have to have plastic
yeah do all these plastic things so
we'll set them to task on that and all
the coal is being stored here which is
great so now there's no excuse to have
coal in those machines
there's no excuse you guys should be
done you guys want to live another life
you don't have to do this you're all you
there's more to life than just those
that battery's kind of full hee-hoo
there's research to be done Hugh
there you go by hee-hoo all right these
guys aren't gonna know what to do
besides running we're gonna be so
confused three two one and stop there we
go yes yeah you did it you did it well
yeah they did it Wow they're proud of
themselves
oh that makes me feel happy I don't know
why but that makes me feel very happy
they did it they're very happy are we
doing here 29.5 that's not better that's
worse that's worse what I thought it was
getting better after took it lights out
but apparently there's more heat than
just the lights in here maybe it's all
this heat generating things here I hate
it I hate heat I hate the heat the heat
is hate Oh we're gonna run into a
problem we just don't have we don't have
what we need
all right I'm gonna end this one here
just because I don't know what else to
do for now I I need to think about this
because I need to get the temperature
down this has been like the boogeyman
that's lying in your closet right behind
you and if you turn around then
really be pissed off so I gotta address
this eventually just like you gotta
address that eventually thank you
everybody so much for watching we're
very close to the brink of death because
as soon as the temperature gets too high
then all my food production goes out the
window and then everyone starts starving
and then I got to make mush bars and
then I run out of water and then I don't
run out of power because everyone's
making bush bars and then I can't
produce the power to be able to make the
most bars and that everyone dies that's
how this works
so we're gonna try to book for that
because I'm not a worrying kind of
person Oh No thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye
[Music]